I'm going to
share with you what
I intended to say if I
had been elected in 2016.
"My fellow Americans,
today, you sent a message
to the whole world".
Everybody will be knocked
down, the question
is, will you get back up?
I want to share my life
lessons with the hope
that it might help you, as
you navigate your own life.
I made so many
gaffes and mistakes.
There are steps you can take to
build confidence in yourself;
to begin to trust yourself about
the decisions you will make.
This class is for
anyone, at any age, who
wants to think about building
a life of meaning and purpose;
of having a mission
that captures what
you're willing to stand up for.
Everyone, every one of you, has
the ability to be resilient.
I've been, you know,
reduced to tears,
i've been frustrated
beyond words,
but the lesson that I've
learned about getting back
up after setbacks
or disappointments,
is to first feel
the disappointment.
Don't pretend it didn't happen.
It did.
You have to authentically
dig deep to get back up.
I'm Hillary Rodham Clinton,
and this is MasterClass.